the aftermath of a tragedy is the
Italian Coast Guard retrieved the Dead
this video posted on social media shows
some of the dozens of bodies which
washed up on the eastern coast of
Calabria
more bodies were spotted at sea
these photos show local firefighters
looking for survivors
it was night time when a ship crashed on
the Rocks during rough weather near the
resort of staccato di cutro it was
reportedly carrying as many as 150
people many of them were from
Afghanistan
a baby and several children are among
the Dead
scores of people have been rescued alive
and are being treated by the Emergency
Services
Italy's interior Minister has called the
incident a huge tragedy which shows the
absolute need to act firmly against
irregular migration channels according
to the international organization for
migration more than 20 000 people have
died or gone missing in the central
Mediterranean since 2014. Nadine barber
Al Jazeera
is head of operation Communications at
the rescue organization SOS
Mediterranean she says that measures to
prevent dangerous illegal sea migrations
have been effective
the whole Mediterranean is a masquerade
and the central Mediterranean
specifically the root where we associate
and they operate in between Libya and
Europe it is the deadliest sea migration
route in the whole world
um indeed people and when we say people
is not only men it's women and children
and this tragedy recalls that again
because children apparently uh sadly
died today
um people depart
um
no question of will they be rescued or
not but the thing is and it's very
difficult to understand
people depart on Cross in these very
very dangerous routes on and seaworlds
overcrowded boats often without even
life jackets seeking safety that's crazy
they're enriching their life to seek
safety but that is what is happening
it's been happening since 2015 and we
need to absolutely understand that and
be ready present and have as many
Maritime assets and certain Rescue
Services available to rescue these
people